alhamdulillah wa salatu was-salam ala
rasulillah sallallahu alayhi wasallam
I'm a bad brothers and sisters both
Muslims and non-muslims welcome to the
video I just want to ask you a couple of
questions have you heard of al-qaeda I'm
sure you have have you heard of Boko
Haram I'm sure you have have you heard
of Leary could be butchered to death a
year ago I'm sure you have I want to ask
me another question though have you
heard of a man from Birmingham an
elderly man coming from the messages
from a mosque and he gets butchered to
death and the same man that kills him it
plots to build to blow up a mosque have
you heard of this I don't think you have
have you heard of a Muslim sister in
Paris being kicked and she had to lose
how a baby you haven't heard of this
right have you heard of a man from
California an old man who was an ex-army
veteran he drives all the way from
California to Detroit to blow a Moscow
which has 500 members have you heard of
this no you haven't
please ask yourself this question why
don't you hear it when a Muslim is doing
the killing a so-called Muslim it's all
around the media but when a Muslim is
being killed it is nowhere to be found
and nobody knows about it why he Proctor
see why this double standard please ask
yourself why did you know that last week
an ex-army veteran from California was
arrested for driving to Detroit the
largest mosque for the trunk full of
explosives roger Stockham 63 had driven
from california to michigan and had been
drinking in a detroit bar on monday when
he threatened to do harm to Detroit area
mosque and a bar employee followed the
man outside wrote down his license plate
and called Detroit police police then
found the man inside of his car outside
the Islamic center of America where more
than five hundred members were gathered
for a funeral and in his car he had a
load of m-80s and other explosives in
the trunk now whatever damage he was
planning was a verdict thanks to
authorities but the mainstream media has
completely ignored this story now just
imagine if the same thing had happened
but the perpetrator was a Muslim man his
mug shot would be on every TV screen
every hour you see brothers and sisters
there is
a new murder that we want to bring to
light that you most definitely have not
heard of and this murder has taken place
during the World Cup in fact two days
ago what we're doing down here in Brazil
we heard that Tuesday morning a sister
who was rang and a buyer with a hijab in
colchester in Essex was brutally
murdered inside a park at 10:50 a.m. in
the morning she was walking and they
murdered her a guy murdered her in cold
blood
with a knife paramedics arrived tries to
save her at the scene but a loss for
Hanna thought I'd word that she would
not survive and she died but you know
what's disgusting about this is that
when the Daily Mail reported it they
didn't even mention that she was a
Muslim just said a woman about 30 years
old was murdered today and what's even
more insulting is that the couple of
places where we did hear the news it's
like they're trying to act like we don't
know it was connected to Islam it might
have been connected to the fact that she
was wearing Islamic dress here using any
excuse to not relate to Islam but when a
Muslim does it they find every excuse to
relate to Islam and that's a very valid
point okay but you know what we're not
gonna leave you just asking the question
of why because we know what the answer
is the answer is that damn media does
things in their way right I'm gonna stay
there I want to mother British media I'm
some of the specific individuals
internationally who have a global agenda
because we consider ourself British
individuals right on that note we're
Muslim British individuals and we also
have our own media we also have access
to basically put the message across and
make people known of the troubles that
are occurring so I'm gonna call some
names out right now and please don't
take this the wrong way
I'm not calling these names up because I
have a personal grudge against you in
any way shape or form I'm important
these names up because I see you as
individuals that could assist the cause
of the Muslims right now I'm gonna name
some youtubers are very famous and
popular right now that across all of you
guys you have millions
millions and millions of YouTube
subscribers and I'm a youtuber myself
don't worry I'm not trying to get no
claim to fame from you guys I don't need
none of that we would do respect I'll do
my thing and we do it nice I haven't
allowed me okay without progress but for
the sake of a lost panel with a de I'm
reaching out to you my brothers and
sisters and hope that you will respond
to the call I'm reaching out to brother
fal'cie true I'm reaching out to brother
Adam starting from true story a si I'm
reaching out to these hijab' youtubers
there is some hair that you can do that
we can both agree upon I'm not attacking
you please I love and respect your
sisters in many ways right and I feel
that you could benefit and we can all
agree upon it so I'm reaching out just
yeah I don't know which sisters right I
don't know I don't want you guys to know
these are the fisa sister call-out this
is just what we've been informed by
people who watch our stuff that you guys
are the most influential in the hijab
YouTube field so since the American
sister Deena Tokyo and nabila be most
honorable Livi okay yeah so anyone that
we didn't mention all we are asking is
look you've got followers just use that
to talk about it to talk about this you
know if they can talk about if they can
talk about us our Deen and portray it as
something that's really bad and this is
what a Dean teaches let's use what they
use against them in a way where we can
show the people the truth you know so
only want you to do is make a video make
a video talking about this specific
issue exposing the media for not for
exposing me of having double standards
when it comes to Muslims that are
suffering right
I specifically mentioned the issue of
the sister who got murdered in essence
and you know what specifically mentioned
the issue of the uncle Salim who got
murdered just before the incident
happened would leave Rigby because that
happen around about the same time
everyone heard about Lee Rigby
but no one heard about uncle Salim an
elderly man who got murdered because of
a racial attack so we're asking you
please make this video and I want
everyone to please tweet these five
individuals at least so they get this
video and they can partake in the higher
right I'm not trying to create division
I'm reaching out to you I'm not being
that guy like Haram ha
I'm not being that guy America let's
come together and let's work together
you have a benefit we have a benefit we
can come together and do much more
benefit I will leave you on one point I
put up a state as about an issue that
took place in Sri Lanka brothers and
sisters were being murdered and
massacred the the mosque was burnt
people were moved out of their houses I
didn't know about this issue until I had
several brothers from Sri Lanka I'm
several sisters emailing me telling me
to raise awareness so I'll put up a stay
as one sister from Colombo which is the
capital of Sri Lanka she dropped a
comment that I want to share with you
that really shook me to my core she said
you know what's weird is that just
recently we were raising money for the
Muslims that were suffering in Syria and
we could never have imagined that just a
few days from that fundraiser people
would have to raise money for us
suffering in Sri Lanka and you know what
brothers and sisters that is exactly
what the person feels like when it
happens to them you think that the
problems happening over there in the
world today happen to you so don't wait
to make this video when it happens to
you or your sister or your mother or
your brother actually has already
happened to your sister your mother or
your brother
so please my beloved brothers and
sisters remember we're asking to tweet
this video to sister American Deena
Tokyo and Avila be brother Farsi tube
and Adam Saudi from true story aka say
no I Love You Man in it it's a love
thing it's not a beef thing yeah come
together you need a thing yeah I love I
love you know it's around one equal I
forgot to share the video remember
what's the message expose the media and
raise awareness of the corruption that's
taking place and and violence against
the Muslims and you don't encourage
other Muslims to partake and setting up
their own media projects because we need
this of course according to Quran and
Sunnah inshallah assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters